Lucia: 然后让我再去粘一下
Lucia: Then let me stick it again.
Tasha: 是不都扔了
Tasha: Did you throw them all away?
Jake:耶你气的
Jake: Yeah, you are really angry.
Lucia: 我靠这是在干什么我靠
Lucia: Damn, what are you doing, damn.
Jake:1234
Jake: 1, 2, 3, 4.
Jake:5
Jake: 5.
Jake:哎呀哎呀
Jake: Oh my, oh my.
Jake:插线板拔了吧
Jake: Unplug the power strip.
Jake:咱把插线板都都给拔了吧
Jake: Let's unplug all the power strips.
Shure: 然后打车票子啥的你就留好
Shure: Then keep the taxi receipts and stuff.
Shure: 到时候跟那个小畅报
Shure: Report them to Xiaochang later.
Shure: 没想到吧
Shure: Didn't expect that, did you?
Jake:哼哼确实没想到哼
Jake: Hmm, indeed didn't expect that, hmm.
Lucia: 哎我是不是把那个啥放在
Lucia: Hey, did I put that thing...
Jake:确实很难想这个
Jake: It's really hard to think about this.
Tasha: 我真的想打个耳洞
Tasha: I really want to get an ear piercing.
Lucia: 放在放在哪了想不起来了
Lucia: Where did I put it, can't remember.
Shure: 试试
Shure: Try it.
Shure: 是不是差点就信了
Shure: Almost believed it, didn't you?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 是我袋子吗
Lucia: Is it my bag?
Lucia: 应该不是吧
Lucia: Probably not, right?
Lucia: 哦不是哎那我是什么时候
Lucia: Oh no, when did I...
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 怎么样怎么样这个
Shure: How's this?
Lucia: 哎好怪哦
Lucia: Hey, it's so weird.
Shure: 骗人的本领
Shure: The skill of deception.
Shure: 撒谎不眨眼
Shure: Lying without blinking.
Lucia: 气死
Lucia: I'm so mad.
Tasha: 甩了他他不真心
Tasha: Dump him, he's not sincere.
Shure: 得得得得得得我的心
Shure: Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, my heart.
Alice:这有用吗这还
Alice: Does this work, this still...
Shure: 猜猜这一坨是谁压的
Shure: Guess who squished this pile?
Shure: 是的没错就是我
Shure: Yes, that's right, it's me.
Shure: 我以为他整
Shure: I thought he...
Alice:这坨东西还有用吗
Alice: Is this pile still useful?
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 很有用
Shure: Very useful.
Alice:搁哪
Alice: Where to put it?
Shure: 这几个是谢彬竹的那个我靠
Shure: These few are Xie Binzhu's, oh my...
Shure: 还有一个应该
Shure: There should be one more.
Alice:那要不你给他收起来
Alice: How about you keep them for him?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 这四个是谢彬竹的
Shure: These four are Xie Binzhu's.
Shure: 这个是杨老板
Shure: This one is Jake's.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
Jake:这一层就5个
Jake: There are only five on this layer.
Jake:这种目一词
Jake: This word...
Alice:这是不是搬下去啊
Alice: Should we move this down?
Alice:这个木凳子
Alice: This wooden stool.
Alice:般一个
Alice: Move one.
Shure: 因为没买到刮刮乐
Shure: Because I couldn't buy a scratch card,
Shure: 所以就给大家买个瓜
Shure: So I got everyone a melon.
Lucia: 这粘哪啊我靠
Lucia: Where to stick this, oh my...
Shure: 哎这应该也不缺什么泡沫纸
Shure: Hey, we shouldn't be short on foam paper.
Shure: 盒子什么的东西
Shure: Or boxes or anything.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 这在哪边啊这条鱼
Lucia: Where is this fish?
Shure: 你又做那个青蛙脸干什么
Shure: Why are you making that frog face again?
Shure: 帮我帮我
Shure: Help me, help me.
Shure: 低了一下这个尾巴
Shure: Lower this tail a bit.
Tasha: 我说好像没什么要忙的了
Tasha: I think there's nothing left to do.
Lucia: 喂您好
Lucia: Hello?
Lucia: 呃最近没有谢谢啊
Lucia: Uh, not recently, thank you.
Lucia: 嗯好再见
Lucia: Okay, goodbye.
Lucia: 唉见鬼了
Lucia: Ugh, this is driving me nuts.
Lucia: 早不打晚不打
Lucia: They always call at the worst times.
Lucia: 这会给我打
Lucia: This will hit me.
Lucia: 啊好好好就这样啊
Lucia: Ah, okay okay, just like this.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Lucia: 敷一下啊就这样吧
Lucia: Apply a bit, just like this.
Jake:这个地为什么会这样呢
Jake: Why is this place like this?
Lucia: 可能有饮料之类东西然后他有糖就
Lucia: Maybe there's some drink or something, and it has sugar.
Jake:嗯一地的糖
Jake: Hmm, sugar all over the place.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 现在他的整齐程度就和昨天一模一样
Lucia: Now it's as tidy as it was yesterday.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, good.
Lucia: 我现我现在是不是要到外面
Lucia: Should I go outside now?
Jake:呃还没
Jake: Uh, not yet.
Lucia: 还是
Lucia: Or
Jake:还有几个人
Jake: There are a few more people.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Jake:呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yes.
Jake:等人齐了一起走
Jake: Wait till everyone's here, then we'll go together.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 那就把别的东西整理整理
Lucia: Then let's tidy up the other stuff.
Lucia: 哦这我昨天那个那个啥放这吧
Lucia: Oh, this thing from yesterday, let's put it here.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 他还可以出镜一下
Lucia: It can also be in the shot.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 啊别了
Lucia: Ah, never mind.
Lucia: 我下去把门口整理一下
Lucia: I'll go downstairs and tidy up the entrance.
Katrina: 可以扫吗
Katrina: Can you sweep?
Katrina: 可以先扫我的吗
Katrina: Can you sweep mine first?
Katrina: 因为我有点想睡觉
Katrina: Because I'm a bit sleepy.
Jake:想睡觉
Jake: Sleepy?
Katrina: 我有点不舒服
Katrina: I'm not feeling well.
Jake:好的行呃
Jake: Okay, sure, um.
Lucia: 这个是不可以扔掉的
Lucia: This can't be thrown away.
Lucia: 这好像也是我昨天的墙贴
Lucia: This also seems to be my wall sticker from yesterday.
Lucia: 这是效果示意图
Lucia: This is the illustration of the effect.
Jake:好哈哈可以
Jake: Alright, haha, good.
Jake:微微准备下去吧
Jake: Tasha, get ready to go down.
Jake:在吗
Jake: Are you there?
Jake:准备下去吧
Jake: Get ready to go down.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:走走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 还没掉
Jake:走啦走啦走啦走啦走啦
Jake:哎这是一个好主意
Jake:那你不能动
Jake:你得是可以
Jake:可以可以
Jake:可以可以可以可以可以可以可以
Lucia: 我自己也想拍一下
Jake:好可以拍一下
Jake:真好看小写生活大写爱
Lucia: 谢谢
Jake:生活不在别处
Jake:嗯
Jake:还有一种方案
Jake:就是你们就在自己的房间
Jake:但是不能动
Lucia: 我下去吧
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈难度好高
Jake:就是
Jake:你们就成为你们房间里边的一个
Jake: You guys will just become a part of your room's decor.
Lucia: 装饰是吧
Lucia: Like a decoration, right?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 好可怕啊
Lucia: That's so scary.
Lucia: 现在的研究已经进行到这一步了吗
Lucia: Has the research really come this far now?
Jake:这个就是一个示意图形就是
Jake: This is just a schematic diagram.
Jake:那你到时候就这么坐着
Jake: So you just sit like this at that time.
Jake:你扒东好你扒东
Jake: You hold on, you hold on.
Lucia: 我真的对这个非常满意
Lucia: I'm really satisfied with this.
Lucia: 再给我多点时间
Lucia: Give me more time.
Lucia: 我甚至还能把那个鱼和海浪
Lucia: I could even make the fish and waves look more realistic.
Lucia: 给他装饰的更像一点
Lucia: I could make it look more realistic.
Lucia: 别说您了
Lucia: Not just you.
Lucia: 我自己都想扫一下
Lucia: Even I want to scan it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, good.
Jake:你回头也可以自己扫一下
Jake: You can also scan it yourself later.
Lucia: 就是我应该扫一下
Lucia: I should scan it.
Lucia: 你用的是哪个软件
Lucia: Which software are you using?
Jake:就是3D scan
Jake: It's 3D scan.
Jake:呃对对对
Jake: Uh, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: threed scanner那个
Lucia: The 3D scanner
Jake:3D SCAN
Jake: 3D SCAN
Lucia: OK我之前用过那个
Lucia: OK, I've used that before
Jake:嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, that's good
Tasha: 我也用过
Tasha: I've used it too
Tasha: 我帮你扫另一个房间吧
Tasha: I'll help you scan the other room
Tasha: 哦不行
Tasha: Oh, wait
Lucia: 他他要扫一个
Lucia: He needs to scan one
Tasha: 要要一个设备扫
Tasha: Needs one device to scan
Lucia: 他扫对
Lucia: He's scanning, yes
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 他要扫一个连续的文件
Lucia: He needs to scan a continuous file
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 我是really scattered的
Lucia: I'm really scattered
Lucia: 应该还有
Lucia: There should be more
Lucia: 我上次那个啥的也有可能没有了
Lucia: The last time I used it, it might not be there anymore
Lucia: 因为我这个软件好久没用了
Lucia: Because I haven't used this software in a long time
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:我要上个厕所
Alice: I need to go to the bathroom
Alice:这个不可以录
Alice: This can't be recorded
Jake:好好没问题没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem, no problem
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:可以不录
Jake: It doesn't have to be recorded
Jake:内有恶犬
Jake: Beware of the dog
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈可以
Lucia: Hahahaha, that's funny
Shure: 今天要把这个房子拆成什么样
Shure: How are we supposed to demolish this house today?
Shure: 就是完全恢复原样
Shure: Like, restore it completely
Shure: 我说我们今天要把这房子拆成什么样
Shure: I'm saying, how are we supposed to demolish this house today?
Shure: 晚风吹呀吹
Shure: The evening breeze blows
Shure: 把我这个衣服拿过来
Shure: Bring my clothes over here
Jake:对我这电脑也要全拆了
Jake: Yes, I need to dismantle this computer too
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow
Jake:哦呦
Jake: Oh no
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake:我这电脑还得全
Jake: I still need to dismantle this computer
Jake:也得全拆了
Jake: It also needs to be dismantled
Jake:回头你们还能打把麻将
Jake: Later, you guys can still play mahjong
Shure: 哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh my, oh my
Jake:开心了不
Jake: Are you happy?
Shure: 快快拆
Shure: Hurry, hurry, take it apart.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 我觉得杨老板这屋拆的刻不容缓
Shure: I think Jake's room really needs to be taken apart right away.
Shure: 因为他一直压着那麻将机
Shure: Because he's always pressing down on that mahjong table.
Lucia: 这就是你一直没能打上的原因是吧
Lucia: That's why you haven't been able to play, right?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:对等了一周了
Jake: Yeah, I've been waiting for a week.
Jake:可算能打上了
Jake: Finally, we can play.
Jake:呵垂涎三尺
Jake: I'm drooling over it.
Lucia: 哎呀这就剩一个了
Lucia: Oh, there's only one left.
Lucia: 我给大家收拾收拾
Lucia: Let me tidy up for everyone.
Lucia: 尾声呵呵呵
Lucia: The final round, hehe.
Jake:对是是一个麻将的尾声
Jake: Yeah, it's the final round of mahjong.
Jake:然后谁谁赢先谁先走
Jake: And then, whoever wins first, leaves first.
Shure: 小黑你好
Shure: Hi, Nicous.
Jake:呵呵谁赢谁先走
Jake: Haha, whoever wins leaves first.
Lucia: 什么什么
Lucia: What, what?
Lucia: 谁谁谁谁
Lucia: Who, who, who?
Jake:谁先胡谁先胡谁先走
Jake: Whoever wins first leaves first.
Jake:不胡不准走
Jake: No winning, no leaving.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 不扶不准走
Lucia: No winning, no leaving.
Lucia: 妈呀
Lucia: Oh my.
Lucia: 那我
Lucia: Then I...
Shure: 锁好门我要胡把大的
Shure: Lock the door, I want to win big.
Lucia: 那我这种不会打的岂不是走不了了
Lucia: So, I can't leave because I don't know how to play?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 就没有人管我了是吗
Lucia: So, no one is going to help me?
Lucia: 不行那这房间至少要剩下4个人
Lucia: No way, there must be at least 4 people left in this room.
Lucia: 因为当只剩3个人时候就没法打了
Lucia: Because if there are only 3 people left, we can't play.
Shure: 哎我找一个袋子
Shure: Hey, I'm looking for a bag.
Shure: 还剩不剩
Shure: Is there any left?
Shure: 什么盒马的袋子了咱们这
Shure: Any Hema bags left here?
Lucia: 那是我的裤子吗
Lucia: Are those my pants?
Lucia: 这么长时间还没洗完吗
Lucia: They haven't been washed yet?
Lucia: 哦竟然不是
Lucia: Oh, it's not.
Lucia: 是哪位好心人已经帮我把裤子挂上了
Lucia: Who kindly helped me hang my pants?
Katrina: 我哈哈
Katrina: Me, haha.
Lucia: 哦谢谢你
Lucia: Oh, thank you.
Katrina: 没事因为我急着洗
Katrina: It's okay because I'm in a hurry to wash
Lucia: 我就说他应该好了
Lucia: I said he should be done
Lucia: 没洗这么久
Lucia: He hasn't washed for so long
其他人：少什么奶奶哈哈哈
Others: What kind of grandma, hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈那叫老夫人
Shure: Hahaha, it's called madam
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
其他人：哎呀
Others: Oh my
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Oh my
Lucia: 这玩意怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on with this thing
Lucia: 该换个地方放
Lucia: It needs to be placed somewhere else
Shure: 他还有电居然
Shure: It's still powered, unbelievable
Shure: 我在这修了一下午的那那什么家呀
Shure: I spent the whole afternoon fixing this place
Shure: 墙啊桥结果我妹没给
Shure: Walls and bridges, and my sister didn't give it
Shure: 我保存直接给我退了
Shure: I saved it and it just closed on me
Jake:好啊动森
Jake: Okay, Animal Crossing
Jake:疫情那会躺床上就晚是吧
Jake: During the pandemic, we just lay in bed, right
Jake:疫情刚开始那会是
Jake: When the pandemic first started
Shure: 谁知道啊
Shure: Who knows
Shure: 有些为什么
Shure: Some people, why
Shure: 给我收拾
Shure: Clean up for me
Shure: 他就给我带了一件白t四件外套
Shure: He brought me one white T-shirt and four jackets
Shure: 哈哈哈真是正常人类能带过来了
Shure: Hahaha, can a normal person carry that
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Lucia: 我可不可以认领一下这个箱子
Lucia: Can I claim this box
Jake:我要开始扫了可以了吗
Jake: I'm going to start sweeping, okay
Alice:那我下去
Alice: Then I'll go down
Alice:把我再粘粘
Alice: Stick me again
Jake:那你就坐着
Jake: Then just sit there
Jake:你不能动
Jake: You can't move
Alice:啊给我粘胶带
Alice: Ah, stick the tape on me
Alice:开始扫了
Alice: Start sweeping
Alice:干嘛呢你当虫呢
Alice: What are you doing, pretending to be a bug
Alice:能给我粘牢固点吗
Alice: Can you stick it tighter
Alice:这胶随便使
Alice: Use as much tape as you want
Jake:你真不能动啊
Jake: You really can't move
Alice:你可以多沾点好吗
Alice: Can you stick more, please
Lucia: 黑化
Lucia: Turning dark
其他人：你好这有一个小件给您哈嗯
Other Person: Hello, there's a small package for you.
Lucia: 这个是谁的啊
Lucia: Whose is this?
其他人：姓杨的菜鸟的
Other Person: It's for the newbie with the last name Yang.
Lucia: 行行行好嘞好嘞
Lucia: Okay, okay, got it.
Lucia: 我放这就行
Lucia: I'll just leave it here.
Jake:是有人来了吗
Jake: Did someone come by?
Lucia: 有一个快递来了
Lucia: A package arrived.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:你的电
Jake: Your phone.
Jake:我上面可能扫他个20分钟吧
Jake: I'll probably scan it for about 20 minutes.
Jake:然后20分钟之后
Jake: Then after 20 minutes,
Jake:你们就要悄悄的跑到二楼去躲着对
Jake: you guys need to quietly run to the second floor to hide, right?
Alice:哈哈哈那你要不多沾点
Alice: Hahaha, why don't you just get a little more involved?
Jake:上装备开凿
Jake: Gear up and start drilling.
Jake:插管
Jake: Insert the tube.
Jake:哈哈插一圈管开扫
Jake: Haha, insert a row of tubes and start sweeping.
Alice:哈哈哈我还没说呢
Alice: Hahaha, I haven't even said anything yet.
Alice:我靠我真服了
Alice: Damn, I really give up.
Lucia:  （歌词）but we don't have to be
Lucia: (Lyrics) but we don't have to be
Lucia: （歌词）but i'll do it in the best way
Lucia: (Lyrics) but I'll do it in the best way
Lucia: （歌词）i'll be the guardian of all your favorite chains
Lucia: (Lyrics) I'll be the guardian of all your favorite chains
Lucia: （歌词）i am the center of the heaven for the cover glass
Lucia: (Lyrics) I am the center of the heaven for the cover glass
Lucia: 靠这这这首歌我咋不记得调了
Lucia: Damn, why don't I remember the tune of this song?
Lucia: （歌词）i tried to picture me without you
Lucia: (Lyrics) I tried to picture me without you
Lucia: （歌词）but i can't cause it could be immortals immortals
Lucia: (Lyrics) but I can't cause it could be immortals, immortals
Lucia: （歌词）just not for long for long
Lucia: (Lyrics) just not for long, for long
Lucia: （歌词）if it's just me again and again everyday
Lucia: (Lyrics) if it's just me again and again every day
Lucia: （歌词）i'm still comparing your to my futures
Lucia: (Lyrics) I'm still comparing your to my futures
Lucia: （歌词）it might be over like rostitious
Lucia: (Lyrics) it might be over like rostitious
Lucia: （歌词） i am the seventh autumn half of the hourglass
Lucia: (Lyrics) I am the seventh autumn half of the hourglass
Lucia: 我靠我是多久没听这首歌了
Lucia: Damn, how long has it been since I listened to this song?
Lucia: （歌词）follow
Lucia: (Lyrics) follow
Lucia: （歌词）just love follow follow
Lucia: (Lyrics) just love follow follow
Lucia: 哇塞要我命了
Lucia: Wow, this is killing me.
Lucia: （歌词）stick for stick fine and high zoggy sign
Lucia: (Lyrics) stick for stick fine and high zoggy sign
Lucia: （歌词）onto my very common liar mr winter
Lucia: (Lyrics) onto my very common liar Mr. Winter
Lucia: （歌词）grush pitman's
Lucia: (Lyrics) grush pitman's
Lucia: （歌词）hit Mars
Lucia: (Lyrics) hit Mars
Lucia: （歌词）miss the cobba out in the gal
Lucia: (Lyrics) miss the cobba out in the gal
Lucia: （歌词）the the dining plaza
Lucia: (Lyrics) the the dining plaza
Lucia: dinner on Oct
Lucia: （歌词）blooming stick let's start
Lucia: (lyrics) blooming stick let's start
Lucia: （歌词）denying this is the way v via design
Lucia: (lyrics) denying this is the way v via design
Lucia: （歌词）rock and roll is here to stay
Lucia: (lyrics) rock and roll is here to stay
Lucia: （歌词）it's better to burn out than to fade away
Lucia: (lyrics) it's better to burn out than to fade away
Lucia: （歌词）my my hey hey
Lucia: (lyrics) my my hey hey
Lucia: （歌词）out in the blue and into the black
Lucia: (lyrics) out in the blue and into the black
Lucia: （歌词）they give you this but you pay for that
Lucia: (lyrics) they give you this but you pay for that
Lucia: （歌词）and once you're gone you can't ever come back
Lucia: (lyrics) and once you're gone you can't ever come back
Lucia: （歌词）hey hey
Lucia: (lyrics) hey hey
Lucia: （歌词）fish and chips and shipwrecks this is Newfoundland i am
Lucia: (lyrics) fish and chips and shipwrecks this is Newfoundland I am
Lucia: （歌词）i am an islander
Lucia: (lyrics) I am an islander
Lucia: （歌词）：i'm an islander
Lucia: (lyrics) I'm an islander
Lucia: （歌词）i am an islander
Lucia: (lyrics) I am an islander
Lucia: （歌词）i'm an islander
Lucia: (lyrics) I'm an islander
Lucia: （歌词）i am an islander
Lucia: (lyrics) I am an islander
Lucia: （歌词）we will not be killed we will not be drunk
Lucia: (lyrics) we will not be killed we will not be drunk
Lucia: （歌词）we will still go on and
Lucia: (lyrics) we will still go on and
Lucia: （歌词）and a belly rub all barking and meowing for breakfast
Lucia: (lyrics) and a belly rub all barking and meowing for breakfast
Lucia: （歌词）welcome to the rock
Lucia: (lyrics) welcome to the rock
Lucia: okay apple tv all right
Lucia: （歌词）but did you really
Lucia: (lyrics) but did you really
Lucia: harvest moon
Lucia: （歌词）as sweet as lucky as lucky can be ching ching money
Lucia: (lyrics) as sweet as lucky as lucky can be ching ching money
Lucia: （歌词）ching ching money
Lucia: (lyrics) ching ching money
Lucia: （歌词）ching ching Choo
Lucia: (lyrics) ching ching Choo
Lucia: （歌词）good lucky rubber for nice shake hands with you oh
Lucia: (lyrics) good lucky rubber for nice shake hands with you oh
Lucia: （歌词）blow me a kiss and let's lucky too
Lucia: (lyrics) blow me a kiss and let's lucky too
Lucia: （歌词）now as the letter of life has been strong you might finger sweep
Lucia: (lyrics) now as the letter of life has been strong you might finger sweep
Lucia: （歌词）the song bottomless corn
Lucia: (lyrics) the song bottomless corn
Lucia: （歌词）spent with time in ashes and smoke
Lucia: (lyrics) spent with time in ashes and smoke
Lucia: （歌词）in this whole wide world there's no appearing bloke
Lucia: (lyrics) in this whole wide world there's no appearing bloke
Lucia: （歌词）Chin Chin Chin Chin Chin Chin Cherry
Lucia: (lyrics) Chin Chin Chin Chin Chin Chin Cherry
Lucia: （歌词）what's prepared as lucky as lucky can be
Lucia: (lyrics) what's prepared as lucky as lucky can be
Lucia: （歌词）Chin Chin Chin Chin Chin Chinchu
Lucia: (lyrics) Chin Chin Chin Chin Chin Chinchu
Lucia: （歌词）good luck will rough off when i shakes hands with you
Lucia: (lyrics) good luck will rough off when I shake hands with you
Lucia: （歌词）chim chim Cherry you're sweet as as lucky as lucky can be
Lucia: (lyrics) chim chim Cherry you're sweet as as lucky as lucky can be
Lucia: （歌词）chim chim Cherry chim chim Cherry
Lucia: (lyrics) chim chim Cherry chim chim Cherry
Lucia: （歌词）good luck we're robed of when i shake hands with you and i
Lucia: (lyrics) good luck we're robed of when I shake hands with you and I
Lucia: （歌词）one nice shakes hand with you
Lucia: (Lyrics) one nice shakes hand with you
Lucia: （歌词）i chase my brushes with price
Lucia: (Lyrics) i chase my brushes with price
Lucia: （歌词）as i do a room for the chef and a brush for the flu
Lucia: (Lyrics) as i do a room for the chef and a brush for the flu
Lucia: （歌词）a fair smoke is on blurred and curred
Lucia: (Lyrics) a fair smoke is on blurred and curred
Lucia: （歌词）between pavements and stars
Lucia: (Lyrics) between pavements and stars
Lucia: （歌词）in the sweet world
Lucia: (Lyrics) in the sweet world
Lucia: （歌词）when hardly no day
Lucia: (Lyrics) when hardly no day
Lucia: （歌词）no hardly no night
Lucia: (Lyrics) no hardly no night
Lucia: （歌词）there are things half in shadow and half way in light
Lucia: (Lyrics) there are things half in shadow and half way in light
Lucia: （歌词）on the rooftops of London oh还没扫好吗
Lucia: (Lyrics) on the rooftops of London oh haven't you finished sweeping yet?
Lucia: h还没扫好吗
Lucia: h haven't you finished sweeping yet?
Lucia: （歌词） chim chiminey chim chiminey chim chim cherry
Lucia: (Lyrics) chim chiminey chim chiminey chim chim cherry
Lucia: （歌词）when your walls sweep you are glad to company
Lucia: (Lyrics) when your walls sweep you are glad to company
Lucia: （歌词）no words ever more
Lucia: (Lyrics) no words ever more
Lucia: （歌词）have beer crew than the messages
Lucia: (Lyrics) have beer crew than the messages
Lucia: （歌词）轻轻的轻轻轻轻唱
Lucia: (Lyrics) softly, softly, softly sing
Lucia: 完了这首没词
Lucia: Finished, this song has no lyrics
Lucia: when you are sweet by your clear company
Lucia: （歌词）when you are sweet by your clear company
Lucia: (Lyrics) when you are sweet by your clear company
Lucia: （歌词）i've been staring at the edge of the water
Lucia: (Lyrics) i've been staring at the edge of the water
Lucia: （歌词）long as i can remember
Lucia: (Lyrics) long as i can remember
Lucia: （歌词）never really knowing why
Lucia: (Lyrics) never really knowing why
Lucia: （歌词）i wish i could be the perfect daughter
Lucia: (Lyrics) i wish i could be the perfect daughter
Lucia: （歌词）but i come back to the water no matter how我的船
Lucia: (Lyrics) but i come back to the water no matter how my boat
Lucia: （歌词）every turn i take
Lucia: (Lyrics) every turn i take
Lucia: （歌词）every trial i check
Lucia: (Lyrics) every trial i check
Lucia: （歌词）every path i make
Lucia: (Lyrics) every path i make
Lucia: （歌词）every road leads back to a place i know
Lucia: (Lyrics) every road leads back to a place i know
Lucia: （歌词）where i cannot go where i long to be
Lucia: (Lyrics) where i cannot go where i long to be
Lucia: （歌词）see the light when the sky meets the sea
Lucia: (Lyrics) see the light when the sky meets the sea
Lucia: （歌词）and it calls me
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it calls me
Lucia: （歌词）and no one knows how far it goes
Lucia: (Lyrics) and no one knows how far it goes
Lucia: （歌词）no cells can cease this behind me
Lucia: (Lyrics) no cells can cease this behind me
Lucia: （歌词）my girl there's just no telling how far i'll go
Lucia: (Lyrics) my girl there's just no telling how far i'll go
Lucia: （歌词）i know everybody on this island seems so happy on this island
Lucia: (Lyrics) i know everybody on this island seems so happy on this island
Lucia: （歌词）everything is by design
Lucia: (Lyrics) everything is by design
Lucia: （歌词）i know everybody on this island has a role of this island
Lucia: (Lyrics) i know everybody on this island has a role of this island
Lucia: （歌词）maybe i can roll with mine
Lucia: (Lyrics) maybe i can roll with mine
Lucia: （歌词）i can lead with pride i can make it strong
Lucia: (Lyrics) i can lead with pride i can make it strong
Lucia: （歌词）i'll be satisfied if i play along
Lucia: (Lyrics) i'll be satisfied if i play along
Lucia: （歌词）but the voice inside sings a different song
Lucia: (Lyrics) but the voice inside sings a different song
Lucia: （歌词）seem to lie at the sky at the sea
Lucia: (Lyrics) seem to lie at the sky at the sea
Lucia: （歌词）and it's blinding no wonder
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it's blinding no wonder
Lucia: （歌词）but deeper go
Lucia: (Lyrics) but deeper go
Lucia: （歌词）and it seems like it's calling out to me
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it seems like it's calling out to me
Lucia: （歌词）so come find me
Lucia: (Lyrics) so come find me
Lucia: （歌词）let me know
Lucia: (Lyrics) let me know
Lucia: （歌词）what's beyond that line where i cross that line
Lucia: (Lyrics) what's beyond that line where I cross that line
Lucia: （歌词）seen a line where the sky meets the sea
Lucia: (Lyrics) seen a line where the sky meets the sea
Lucia: （歌词）and it calls me
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it calls me
Lucia: 不对
Lucia: No, that's not right.
Lucia: （歌词）how far it goes
Lucia: (Lyrics) how far it goes
Lucia: （歌词）if the wind in my sails stays the sea stays behind me
Lucia: (Lyrics) if the wind in my sails stays the sea stays behind me
Lucia: （歌词）how far i'll go
Lucia: (Lyrics) how far I'll go
Lucia: 不对
Lucia: No, that's not right.
Lucia: （歌词）still i've been staring at the edge of the water at the
Lucia: (Lyrics) still I've been staring at the edge of the water at the
Lucia: （歌词）the edge of the water
Lucia: (Lyrics) the edge of the water
Lucia: （歌词）long as long as long as long as long as long as i can remember
Lucia: (Lyrics) long as long as long as long as long as long as I can remember
Lucia: （歌词）i've been staring at the edge of the water
Lucia: (Lyrics) I've been staring at the edge of the water
Lucia: （歌词）long as i can remember
Lucia: (Lyrics) long as I can remember
Lucia: （歌词）never really knowing why
Lucia: (Lyrics) never really knowing why
Lucia: （歌词）i wish i could be the perfect dollar
Lucia: (Lyrics) I wish I could be the perfect daughter
Lucia: （歌词）but i'll come back to the water
Lucia: (Lyrics) but I'll come back to the water
Lucia: （歌词）no matter how hard i try
Lucia: (Lyrics) no matter how hard I try
Lucia: （歌词）every every turn i take
Lucia: (Lyrics) every every turn I take
Lucia: （歌词）every trial i check
Lucia: (Lyrics) every trial I check
Lucia: （歌词）every path i make
Lucia: (Lyrics) every path I make
Lucia: （歌词）every turn i take every i check every path i make
Lucia: (Lyrics) every turn I take every trial I check every path I make
Lucia: （歌词）every road leads back to the place i know
Lucia: (Lyrics) every road leads back to the place I know
Lucia: （歌词）where i cannot go where i long to be
Lucia: (Lyrics) where I cannot go where I long to be
Lucia: （歌词）see the light when the sky meets the sea
Lucia: (Lyrics) see the light when the sky meets the sea
Lucia: （歌词）and it calls me hmm hmm hmm hmm
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it calls me hmm hmm hmm hmm
Lucia: （歌词）see the light when the sky meets the sea
Lucia: (Lyrics) see the light when the sky meets the sea
Lucia: （歌词）and it calls me
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it calls me
Lucia: （歌词）and it it calls it calls me
Lucia: (Lyrics) and it it calls it calls me
Lucia: （歌词）it calls me it call it calls me
Lucia: (Lyrics) it calls me it call it calls me
Lucia: （歌词）how far i'd go
Lucia: (Lyrics) how far I'd go
Lucia: （歌词）if the wind in my soul still see stays behind me
Lucia: (Lyrics) if the wind in my soul still see stays behind me
Lucia: （歌词）stays behind me
Lucia: (Lyrics) stays behind me
Lucia: （歌词）if i go there's just no telling
Lucia: (Lyrics) If I go there's just no telling
Lucia: （歌词）how far i'll go
Lucia: (Lyrics) How far I'll go
Lucia: （歌词）i know everybody on this island seems so happy on this island
Lucia: (Lyrics) I know everybody on this island seems so happy on this island
Lucia: （歌词）everything is on designer
Lucia: (Lyrics) Everything is on designer
Lucia: （歌词）i know everybody on this island has a role on this island
Lucia: (Lyrics) I know everybody on this island has a role on this island
Lucia: （歌词）i can live with pride
Lucia: (Lyrics) I can live with pride
Lucia: （歌词）i can make us strong i'll be satisfied
Lucia: (Lyrics) I can make us strong I'll be satisfied
Lucia: （歌词）i'll be satisfied i'll be satisfied i'll be satisfied
Lucia: (Lyrics) I'll be satisfied I'll be satisfied I'll be satisfied
Lucia: （歌词）i'll be satisfied i'll be
Lucia: (Lyrics) I'll be satisfied I'll be
Lucia: （歌词）i'll be satisfied if i play along
Lucia: (Lyrics) I'll be satisfied if I play along
Lucia: （歌词）will you lie when summer's here for me
Lucia: (Lyrics) Will you lie when summer's here for me
Lucia: （歌词）what's beyond that line
Lucia: (Lyrics) What's beyond that line
Lucia: （歌词）the light see the light miss the sky
Lucia: (Lyrics) The light see the light miss the sky
Lucia: （歌词）miss the sea and it calls me
Lucia: (Lyrics) Miss the sea and it calls me
Lucia: 我靠这个怎么老不
Lucia: Why does this always...
Lucia: （歌词）it calls
Lucia: (Lyrics) It calls
Lucia: （歌词）if the wind in my soul doesn't see
Lucia: (Lyrics) If the wind in my soul doesn't see
Lucia: （歌词）stays behind me
Lucia: (Lyrics) Stays behind me
Lucia: （歌词）人的轮廓
Lucia: (Lyrics) The outline of a person
Lucia: （歌词）海浪无声将夜幕深深淹没
Lucia: (Lyrics) The waves silently submerge the night deeply
Lucia: （歌词）漫过天空尽头的角落
Lucia: (Lyrics) Over the corners of the sky's edge
Lucia: （歌词）大鱼在梦境的缝隙里游过
Lucia: (Lyrics) The big fish swims through the gaps of dreams
Lucia: （歌词）凝望你沉睡的轮廓
Lucia: (Lyrics) Gazing at your sleeping outline
Lucia: （歌词）看海天一色听风起雨落
Lucia: (Lyrics) Watching the sea and sky blend, listening to the wind and rain
Lucia: （歌词）执子手吹散苍茫茫烟波
Lucia: (Lyrics) Holding your hand, blowing away the vast mist
Lucia: （歌词）大鱼的翅膀已经太辽阔
Lucia: (Lyrics) The wings of the big fish are already too vast
Lucia: （歌词）我松开时间的绳索
Lucia: (Lyrics) I let go of the rope of time
Lucia: （歌词）更怕你永远停留在这里
Lucia: (Lyrics) More afraid of you staying here forever
Lucia: （歌词）漫过天空尽头的角落
Lucia: (Lyrics) Over the corners of the sky's edge
Lucia: （歌词）大鱼在梦境的缝隙里
Lucia: (Lyrics) The big fish swims through the gaps of dreams
Lucia: （歌词）游过往沉睡的轮廓
Lucia: (Lyrics) Passing through the sleeping outlines
Lucia: （歌词）我松开时间的绳索
Lucia: (Lyrics) I let go of the rope of time